bienvenidos nuevamente hagamos unos
cuantos más problemas del juego de los
ángulos y esperemos que con esto te
conviertas en un experto del juego de
los ángulos así que aquí tengo otra vez
la estrella y digamos que conozco los
siguientes ángulos conocemos conocemos
este ángulo y bueno el cual mide 41
grados conocemos este otro ángulo este
ángulo grande el cual mide 113 grados
103 grados y conocemos finalmente este
ángulo ajá este ángulo mide 101 grados
ahora lo que queremos averiguar la meta
de el juego de los ángulos queremos
averiguar cuánto mide cuánto mide este
ángulo y bueno como siempre te invito a
que lo intentes pone pausa el vídeo e
intenta llegar al resultado ahora si no
lo puedes hacer bueno puedes de poner
seguir al vídeo así que pone pausa ahora
porque ya voy a explicar común cómo se
hace esto vale o que muy bien bueno yo
conozco yo conozco este ángulo este y
éste hay que ver cuánto mide este ángulo
naranja entonces cómo podemos averiguar
eso cuáles son las posibles estrategias
si supiéramos cuánto mide en este ángulo
entonces diríamos que son suplementarios
pero no parece sencillo porque no está
en un triángulo ese ángulo así que bueno
pero este ángulo si es parte de un
triángulo cierto entonces si pudiéramos
conocer cuánto miden estos dos ángulos
este ángulo y éste lo voy a poner en
verde en este y este entonces bueno se
podría hacer lo que estamos buscando ya
directamente así que puede ser un buen
momento para poner pausa porque te acabo
de dar una pista así que veamos este
ángulo verde es suplementario a este
otro ángulo así que suman 180 si éste
mide 101 entonces este ángulo verde mide
79 grados cierto porque son ángulos
suplementarios por lo tanto este ángulo
verde mide 79 grados y bueno ya tenemos
ahí uno de los primeros ángulos que que
sirve para ver lo que queremos encontrar
ok como podemos averiguar este ángulo
bueno está este combo que solitario en
algún lugar en alguna esquina
del universo entonces pero pero ya
sabemos que es parte de este triángulo
aunque no nos ayuda porque no sabes no
conocemos ese ese ángulo naranja pero
pertenece a otro triángulo claro que sí
a este otro grande mira entonces por eso
por eso me gusta este problema de la
estrella porque tiene tantos triángulos
tal vez no sea muy obvio para ti pero si
observas bien podrás ver muchos
triángulos entonces es parte de este
triángulo y también es parte de este
otro triángulo que voy a que voy a
calcar con otro color ajá para que para
que veas es parte de este otro triángulo
ay no aquí ok este triángulo ahí lo
puedes ver entonces tenemos este
triángulo del cual conocemos ya dos de
sus ángulos cierto el de 41 grados y el
de 113 grados
entonces conocemos conocemos este ángulo
y este otro ángulo entonces este ángulo
más 113 grados más 41 grados es igual a
180 porque la suma de los ángulos
internos de un triángulo es igual a 182
son ángulos internos entonces llamaré
a este ángulo lo llamaré
así que este es el ángulo que no sabemos
qué
+ 113 grados más 113 grados más 41
grados es igual a 180 grados recuerda
que estamos viendo este triángulo a
entonces esto es igual a 180 grados y
luego tenemos kg más cuánto es esto esto
es como
154 grados no sé si estoy bien no sé si
se la cuenta bien pero bueno supongamos
que sí bueno ok creo que sí está bien
entonces que es igual a 26 grados 26
grados por lo tanto ya casi terminamos
ajá que es igual a 26 grados bueno
veamos veamos tenemos tenemos tenemos
estoy repitiendo mucho tenemos este
triángulo tenemos este triángulo
y ya conocemos dos de sus ángulos de
este pequeño triángulo a nuestra meta el
cual es llamemos a este ángulo naranja x
nuestra meta es averiguar cuánto mide
ese ángulo entonces tenemos que x más 26
grados más 79 grados
recordemos que 79 suplementario a este
ángulo luego tenemos que eso es igual a
180 entonces esto es igual a 105 x 105
grados es igual a 180 grados así que
tenemos que x es igual a 75 grados x es
igual a 75 grados y ya hemos terminado
hemos terminado ahora hagamos otro
problema parecido a este ya que estamos
en esto y es bastante divertido entonces
voy a borrar lo que tengo yo aquí vamos
a voy a borrar aquí esto para una nueva
nuevo dibujo entonces ahí está ok vamos
a seguir con esto voy a dibujar aquí dos
triángulos uno junto al otro
así que dibujo cada lado del triángulo
un triángulo grande y después lo voy a
dividir con una línea tenemos ya un
triángulo y lo voy a dividir con esta
línea para tener dos triángulos como
dije uno junto al otro así que veamos
veamos que sabemos sobre este triángulo
a bojan a definir o voy a poner número a
algunos ángulos digamos que este ángulo
todo este ángulo mide mide a 86 grados
entonces este mide 86 grados y sabemos
que este ángulo mide 28 grados
y también sabemos que este ángulo mide
122° 122 grados
ahora nuestra meta es nuestra nuestra
razón de ser nuestra misión en esta vida
la razón por la que llegamos es para
averiguar cuánto mide este ángulo rosa
ajá entonces ok vamos a averiguar cuánto
mide ese ángulo podríamos saber cuánto
mide este ángulo luego restárselo al
ángulo de 86 grados y obtendríamos la
respuesta así que bueno hagamos eso
conocemos los ángulos de este triángulo
llamemos a este ángulo verde y entonces
este es yen y sabemos que ya más 122
grados más 28 grados es igual a 180
grados entonces y es igual a 150 grados
creo si 150 grados es igual a 180 por lo
tanto y es igual a 30 grados ya lo
tenemos entonces si este ángulo mide 30
grados y este ángulo mide 86 grados
nuestra meta
ley de menos de x x será igual a 86
menos 30 grados entonces x es igual a 86
grados menos menos estos 30 grados
por lo tanto x es igual a 56 grados
ahora hay que suponer que no aprendimos
cosa alguna y hay que hay que intentar
hacerlo de una manera distinta entonces
podríamos decir que este ángulo de aquí
es suplementario a este ángulo de 122
grados entonces deben sumar en total 180
grados así que este ángulo más 122 es
igual a 180 por lo tanto este ángulo
mide 58 grados ajá este ángulo mide 58
grados si podemos averiguar cuánto mide
este ángulo sabremos cuánto mide x
entonces cómo podemos saber cuánto mide
ese ángulo podemos podríamos enfocarnos
en este triángulo grande
muy bien ahora sabemos que este ángulo
me de 86 este 28 y a este llamémosle z
entonces sabemos que sabemos que z más
28 grados más 86 grados es igual a 180
ajá entonces 7 es igual a cuánto es esto
es más setama 114° 114 es igual a 180 y
ahora am 11 está es igual a 66 grados no
sé si estoy haciendo bien las cuentas
pero ok z es igual a 66 grados así que
este ángulo mide 58 y ahora podemos usar
este triángulo este triángulo para
averiguar cuánto mide cuánto mide este
ángulo ajá entonces muy bien tenemos que
x 66 más 58 es igual a 180 grados creo
que hice algo mal aquí en las cuentas no
sé si se vio en la suma pero
tengo tengo que x es igual a 180 menos
124 ajá sí sí sí sí es 180 menos 124 lo
cual es igual a x es igual a 56 entonces
x es igual 56 así que si se ven las
cuentas y como puedes ver lo que hicimos
lo que hicimos fue hacerlo hacer esto de
dos maneras distintas y obtuvimos el
mismo resultado entonces ahí aprendiste
dos maneras distintas de hacer esto
espero te haya gustado el juego de los
ángulos y me encantó
así que ve ve ahora y juega lo con tus
amigos
hagan problemas y resuelvan los nos
vemos pronto
bye